my lips my lips feel like they bleed and
those going on hey what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans you're watching hot ones it's the
show with hot questions and even hotter
wings today I'm joined by Kevin Hart
damn right you are
he needs no introduction the new film
what now yeah it was out October 14th
yes and this ain't no Netflix special
you guys had a budget yeah this is uh
this is the real deal Sean you know we
went all the way I filmed it at a
football stadium which has never been
done it's a dope thing to do made
history 52,000 people and I actually put
a mini action movie in front of a comedy
show that gets me to the special so
different and before we begin you tell
this great story about how early on in
your career you're a bombing on stage
and someone pelted you with a half-eaten
chicken hundred percent sure I figured
all that the worst memory ever little
sauce was on the - some of that sauce
got my he and me with a buffalo wing my
joke frustrated him to the point where
he felt the need to stand up and throw
food afterwards is never good you know
it's never good and I say who threw it
you know you expected to be quiet so you
can say some stuff to just look like
you're about to defend yourself and he
was like I did [ __ ] good throw and I'm
just good night I just gone sticky
because it's so chicken wings won Kevin
Hart zero I'm ready to even the score
I'm ready
[Music]
so this first one is sriracha the first
it should be easy to write so what now
is unlike any comedy feature I've ever
seen in my life with the sold-out
Philadelphia Eagle Stadium looking like
a damn Beyonce concert damn right it
does you've said that you train like an
athlete but you seem to be motivated
like one two you want to hang a banner
you want to put on the ring for me it's
it's about history it's about making
sure that last name heart means
something when it's all said and done
you know my kids I want them to
understand not only who their father is
but why he's in a position that he's in
doing this particular movie this is
putting me in position to become closer
to the ultimate goal and and that
ultimate goal is just history man is
history history history so this one's
Tapatio Tapatio take a bite of that that
ain't nothing my top-of-t I ain't never
baby my own hot [ __ ] thinking back on
your jobs that you had before you were
famous do you have fonder memories as a
shoe salesman or that summer that you
were a lifeguard somehow I was a
lifeguard for two reasons first of all
being a shoe salesmen was amazing but
being a lifeguard that's where some of
the funniest stuff has ever happened yes
a little boy almost drowned on my watch
because I thought he was playing and I'm
you know the other lifeguard from across
jumped in to save him and he was like
heart what happened I thought in the
plan not a good excuse kids play too
much so there you had been playing like
you were drowning just to get me in the
water to go high right wasn't drowning
it just so happened at that time he was
drowning let's and learn this is oh you
kept Echo Caribbean habanero who taught
you the enunciation of this stuff
goodness what did you call this I would
call it the e battle that the star would
eat would you say is you can what well
you could take out Caribbean have in
Europe I'm right we won't drink the tech
go see that scab nicknamed
we're gonna drink some of this tech Oh
baby so everyone knows so mm-hmm
this is tech Oh we get Hollywood whoo
going up going up going up we out here
now so everyone
the Kevin Hart in 2016 starring in
blockbusters nominating social media but
I don't think a lot of people know how
water hard that road is you know getting
paid in french fries we've been in your
car and one of the strangest tidbits
that stands out to me used to do gigs at
a place called Sweet Cheeks Sweet Cheeks
where you warmed up the crowds trionic
male dance yes first of all I don't want
to buddy judging me okay you know my
friends are looking at me differently
they don't know the whole story but this
was a different time in my life Sweet
Cheeks was male strip club and I I
wasn't dancing right
yeah you know I would basically okay let
me explain it so the strippers they
would be stripping right and they would
stop the strippers there but art fellows
going to back you know they got to go in
the back and change right so the name
would go body changing and you guys so
going we got some comedy and it wasn't
really a good segue and it doesn't seem
like it would be it would go from the
male strippers there we go introducing a
little cab the bastard that was my name
at the time and I was on stage one time
and as late as I pull your dick out wait
a minute
I ain't even about that I'm up here
slinging these jokes I'm here for the
joke life you know but they didn't want
to hear that
the name love is pain is good I'm saying
it's not pain is bad well what's the
marketing behind that I don't understand
that okay let's go ahead mm-hmm oh yeah
oh yeah oh [ __ ]
so speaking of early on in your career
one of the first IMDB credits you have
is this film called paper soldiers we
have a very unique project yes it was
this Dame - jay-z Rockefeller production
you star alongside beanie sigel and
Memphis Bleek when you look back on that
project and that time in your career
what do you take away that was a good
time man you know that's - beginning
shots out - damn - damn - saw me perform
and Caroline's comedy club he wanted to
talk to me after told me he had a funny
idea we meet we discuss it he said I
want you to star in it he said I got
some other comedians the other comedians
and I got together Charlie Murphy helped
write and navigate the story to where it
could become a real funny comedy and
beans came in and we developed something
that was dope like it wasn't supposed to
be but it was and ended up surpassing
what we thought it was going to do and
act as a vehicle for me you know paper
soldiers is one of the reasons why I was
able to get a tape and get management
you know go out and get an agent you
know just get people to see that there
was a talent behind a comedian so it
acted as a rule for me at one point
which was good this next hot sauce the
way you're I'm the hot one show okay
you're not the only one enterprising
here so this is y'all you decided okay
this is y'all concoction
yep this is our concoction okay no how
would you is in the middle so it's not
crazy like this stuff coming up but it's
like it's funny that you say that
because it's a transition sauce so it's
sweeter it's not gonna you know okay
gonna set my ass so it's not gonna set
your ass okay all right I think I still
taste a couple of the other ones too
because every time I take another bite
comes back yeah the fire come back well
I'll put it off for a second and then
actually come back like right now I
won't drink the milk
so the next thing is called explain that
Graham and what we've done is we've done
a deep dive on your Instagram pulled a
couple interesting pictures that we just
need more context we need more than the
caption only the bigger picture I just
want to show them to you okay and then
you let me know what's going on okay
Kevin Hart and his best man oh man
that's me and my god it's made my
handsome son man my best man
reason why my son was my best man is
because he's my best friend
and I felt that my son should be there
for his dad on his big day and before
the wedding he actually gave a toast in
the back he gave a little quick toast
really some juice and his cup and we all
had a shot he held it up man it was cool
all right so this one squad goals a up
in South Africa yeah yeah what is going
out here what all do the two lions that
I brought when I was in South Africa I
paid 16 million dollars for two lions
you at all scared I don't think so we're
in South Africa we go to the lion what's
it called the lion lion part we go to
the lion park and they're like oh man
we're gonna take you Kevin we're gonna
show you the real deal you got the VIP
treatment you will take you out there
with the Lions and I said ok I don't
know what happened I blacked out and
these guys made us feel so comfortable
but it was by far the stupidest thing
I've ever done it has it would have
stupid safe at any point in time you got
to understand them Lions can have a bad
day and we all just lost sight of
reality we were in the Lions Den walking
with the Lions like that's me really
standing in between two lions yeah it
was the stupidest thing I've ever done
some all-star game high jinks LeBron
James what is he doing he's taking your
drink he's thirsty
uh you know me and Brian have a great
relationship I was at the all-star game
I'm sitting courtside and I talked a lot
of trash and I said something to LeBron
and he was like you had too much to
drink
he took my drink shut you off during the
game when he kept me off and he he took
the truck down he gave to Drake and then
I just looked down drag is sipping my
drink and he's like you had enough
so this one is High River broke okay
it's kind of now we're going up a little
bit
[Music]
Lacey one catching you catching yeah so
I can ask you about hanging out with
celebrities all day but we don't have
all day so I just want to ask you about
one and that's Diddy and when I think
about guys who are like no sleep and
just operating on this brilliant manic
energy I think about diggie and I think
about Kevin Hart do you feel like you
connect on the same wavelength when you
guys are together does this refer to you
you have a story that can kind of put
that in a box for me oh man plus the
cool man
you know publish the dope guy reason why
I said is because he's out that this is
getting hot mm-hmm I don't know what's
wrong with safety we're in Austin but
but there's a [ __ ] going on man
you know I don't know how this is gonna
come out I'm about to [ __ ] [ __ ] fire
this is about to happen man this is hot
but let's go easy tha this emotion is
the motivational guy he's a motivating
guy sorry he's a guy that always wants
more he always was to go above and
beyond the same thing would hold you
know I cried down to this Oprah I can go
on and on Tyler Perry about some of the
people that I personally look at Steve
Harvey that has been mentors that have
taken me to the side I've had amazing
conversations with me you you look at
them in all but in the same sentence and
the same voice you let them know I want
to get to where you are I'm following
your lead of course I'm redirecting and
doing things my way but just know that
your moves are being watched by a
student I'm a student of the game those
are people that have played the game
very well respect are you ready to move
on you know but I'm gonna do it
so this one is 100% pain Wow like is
nothing weird what [ __ ]
I'm not my fabula babe you know I have a
question for chocolate drop up Jay got
cheek in place take it place bad girl in
hip-hop there's all these regional rep
right New York's a little bit cocky ur
LA you have the gangster rap Houston
chopped and spoiled milk
but your hometown of Philly is ground
zero for battle rappers chocolate drop
in your opinion why is your hometown so
great at eating people
how can you hear you man what the why is
my what
why is Philly in your opinion ground
zero for battle rapper hmm oh [ __ ]
Philadelphia oh yeah for there my lips
feel like they bleed and I was going on
there
Philadelphia is just a man
I'm proud of the just the the stance
that battle rap has and Philadelphia you
know people know that we get busy and I
say we because I'm speaking on behalf of
my brother dropper he's one of the
realest man I'm happy for that dude to
see him come and get to where he's now
God he's finally getting the respect
that he deserves a lot of real cars out
there I thought y'all would say go away
go ahead do it
oh I thought I was like what I'm
bleeding what they're not that well
people create this is it just like is it
just like good to be [ __ ] well I
think that actually is when you get to
here you've never put this on a sandwich
it's for psychos
it's when people burned out I see why I
called the Bob with a vision blew up one
of the things that I admire about you
most is your ability to always look at
the glass as half-full
and turn them into a positive so I want
to give you a few between a rock and a
hard place scenarios and you tell me how
you would spin it into a positives
that's I'm good getting booed offstage
similair struggling [ __ ] huh what we say
Dan that ones I want to give you a few
between a rock and a hard place
scenarios and you tell me how you look
at it as glass half-full so I'm good
yeah getting booed off stage okay it
ain't that bad not that bad
all right here's how well my timing my
tongue ain't workin out of lost taste
this this I'm going numb brother okay
here's the thing
it's not that bad reason why it's not
that bad it's because you learn from it
I can't get smacked in the face and just
hold your face you got to go oh [ __ ]
well you can't say go to swing again how
do I
move and how can I smack back everything
was about countering and figuring out
but are ripping a loud farting class in
front of your crush brothers [ __ ]
happens you got you got to take that
baby you know that's what that's what I
did I tell you I say that now yeah my
side got my wife I'm gassy I'm gonna be
gassy today I'll tell you that fellas
what about when you do that thing where
someone waves at you but they're
actually waving at the person behind
them but you think they were waving at
you so you wave back and then you guys
are kind of caught in that weird thing
where they're like dude I wasn't waving
at you and then it's uncomfortable for
everybody put your hand in your pocket
just keep them in your pockets go ahead
back it up
so did you turn around just put a
hanging pocket but how many times have
you done so I've done this 40 times
you're number 41 [ __ ] what's that word
this is mad Dawg 357 yeah a day
I can't even cheat they got it all on so
they only need you take a bite and mat
taste it full-coverage oh [ __ ] we out
here we hold oh man I say we just say
mind since it may be delirious well
that's all I got to do drugs me that's
what it does it gets kind of trippy [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] huh huh here we go
[ __ ] Mad Dog 357 huh that's how a black
dude made this [ __ ] so there always
seems to be two approaches common right
you can either dress like you and Eddie
Murphy guys who dressed like superstars
but the rest of the comedians they all
dress like schlump
probably to seem more relatable can you
tell me the process that you go through
and you pal your outfit for a sold-out
show cuz you seem to think it through
more so than say louis c.k well Oh
uh-huh that was one right there boy
mm-hmm
I like my teeth coming out
hold on by the answer how does that it
yeah I just gotta find it
I gotta get the answer for you brother
hold on hmm oh [ __ ]
clothes are very important to me I feel
like your clothes are clear for
visitation who you are I'm on stage I
love the feel good I look good I love to
look confident my clothes play a major
part in that I'm a stylish cat so hey
man
wing number 10 that Kevin Hart not an
easy road to wing number 10 but here we
are it's tradition around here that we
kind of like dab the last wing you don't
have to if you don't want to I don't
like to pressure people in today you
able person Kevin that's fine by me I
will because otherwise the people they
would be let down but coming back I
should really go through it yep you
don't have to at this point
well should let me read it yeah all
right
that's people's problem they'll read we
warner sauce contains ingredients 500
times hotter than a jalapeno you
sparingly not recommended yeah like just
a little dab that's what you that's
sparingly just a little drop [ __ ] hit
sweating
well mud was a runner yo I'm out here
but break it down there looks like yeah
I feel like a goddamn Koki and I know is
you're sitting
sniffling uh he said here like a [ __ ]
going on I'm over here breaking down
brother come high snap right coming down
but nothing am I said [ __ ] all right ah
what one you use that is this the one
that's the one happen you don't have to
if you don't want to I know it don't
matter right it's already on there yeah
listen what do you have the poop exactly
you build it up pose you took you is
already know you go first
let me go first you go further out I
guess okay what do you got to make right
so as we've talked about you train like
an athlete lots of miles on those hustle
heart smile you on snapchat your trainer
screaming at you every day
what vanity muscles would you say you're
most proud of is it the pecs is it the
biceps and my physical prime there were
my traps I have better traps than Brock
Lesnar what are you most proud about you
[Music]
I mean this this is genius which dog
what y'all got going here is genius
thank you Kevin you out here Brooke yeah
I'm drunk out like I'm drunk I'm drunk
somebody write scum dissolve brother
something's off right now my teeth and
[ __ ] all hot oh well I'm most happy
about is my mental oh I don't even I
don't believe it that's the truth man
I'm in great shape but my mental is so
strong you can say you want to do things
and don't do as you talked about yeah
take your strong mental to actually put
the actions behind it so to wake up
every day at 5:00 5:30 and go to the gym
faithfully and change your lifestyle and
put yourself in a position to just be a
healthier person live a healthier
lifestyle set an example for other
people to see and to inspire and
motivate others I think that's that's
dope you know the physical
transformation I'm I'm happy about it
I'm happy that I'm a fit person but I'm
more proud of the muscle up here and
then my mind I got a strong I have a
strong Lansing you made it through well
it was an incredible performance the
floor is yours
thirty Seconds camera that camera that
camera but the people know we have going
on it okay first and foremost I wanna
give a shout-out to you guys thank you
for having me on thank you for coming
cuz it's a it's a dope it's a dope idea
I heard about it for long
but I get it you're doing an amazing job
um now I take time to address the people
look the guys up a lot of hard work
blood sweat and tears into my crap
okay I'm determined to make this last
name heart mean something the best way
for me to put myself in position to make
history is to do what I do best and
that's tell jokes I love comedy I'm
standing comedian until I die what now
is the finest comedic work that I have
go out go see the movie man it's worth
it
silver 14 help me make history help this
last name means parked Kevin Hart